[Applause]
hi everybody
welcome so girlfriends
is coming to netflix
september 11th our 20th anniversary oh
hell yes
and one would never know it's been 20
years without
a wood chicken chico chico
chipotle
i love it jill's in the mood tap tap tap
in
i just thought that was like really cool
i look naked i like that i don't know
you don't
i do tracy i'll look naked too we'll be
like oh my god
i can't believe it why is persia lit
like like you're on set
i mean no no she looks great
listen look at her
oh
oh hell yes
yes
okay so 2020
2020 which is ridiculous
and persia white golden brooks jelly
bean jill marie jones
um we thought which is the sweetest
thing in the world
we have never had a chance uninterrupted
no moderator no journalist no nobody
yep the bare bones uncensored
uncensored the cast of us together
the core of the girlfriend's show
we thought we would gather these girls
yes
yes
we thought we would gather oh my god
persia that's incredible
it is the holiday weekend and we are all
in our homes across the country some of
us are in l.a some are not
um i also have a cocktail a buble and a
cabernet
but i do have vodka i have an apparel
spritz what do you have persia
just to rosie oh wait cheers everybody
cheers ladies
intro but way worse
where do we want to start with this guys
do you have ideas
we do like and then like girlfriends
[Laughter]
we got a little sneak peek having you
guys on blackish but there's nothing
like the girlfriend's energy did i tell
you
what they said what some of our crew
members said when you guys what
no please they were like we've never
seen you like that tracy i was like
well joan carol clayton was different
than bo johnson
we bring it out we bring it out yeah i
was like
these girls bring out uh a thing in me
yeah
yeah your inner here it was really good
i love
i had so much fun i just you know it's
like we follow each other on instagram
we'll you know like a caption or say hey
girl what's up but there's nothing like
actually being together that collective
energy and i just
we've grown up together the four of us
you
mean literally we have come into our own
and i
i have so many moments with each and
every one of you that i can say
that made me a better person because of
tracy
persia jill you know so i thank you all
for that but that's what
ten years does you know eight to ten
years of your life
i have a question to ask do you guys
remember um
i'm not sure about persia i know that we
both were a part of a recast but do you
remember
the first time that you met us i
remember the first time i met you guys
do you remember did we meet them the
same day
yes at the photo shoot well damn it
you said it
no i think it's great i do remember is
that okay
i mean that's the first time we met and
it was like y'all don't be best friends
and
oh yeah i've met you before hey do you
mean this the photo shoot that is that
iconic girlfriend's
shoot where we were on the couch yeah
was that the one which one it was at
this warehouse and we all
we hadn't met them yet they put them
we had to dance and the camera went
around us and we had a whole new world
yes yes and yeah y'all are best friends
and we're like nice to meet you guys
wait
that photo shoot
not to speak about you guys but
first of all the hair journey on
girlfriends oh gosh
oh gosh it is such a journey
yeah i mean that you can tell what we
were going through by our hairstyles
by the way we wanted to realize that
mean
golden and persia had braces
the clear kind but you can still see
something's off with your mouth
wait and remember there was something we
had to shoot because some of our
things we had
first of all everyone should know that
we have a text thread
yes girlfriendsies it's called
girlfriendsies
and can we set the stage a little bit
for our little dressing room area
yes okay
okay so we were in basically a dorm
space
our dressing rooms were closets they
were cubicles
they were cubicles there was no window
there was a vent in our doors so there
was no privacy
the five of us including reggie in the
beginning shared
a bathroom and then we had that hallway
the common area
which was our common area on our little
text thread
um yes and remembered and i could not
stop
laughing do you guys remember the phase
it was the same season whatever
it was when we were flashing each other
comfortably we would come out of our
rooms and flash each other
oh yeah no no seriously it was a thing
it was a real thing it was working for a
long
time yes i mean we really would we would
go into each other's rooms and
literally i mean i was slightly turned
on guys let's do it
it was a thing run for the road
and i will also say golden and i really
like to show our boots
we do golden golden house
you have amazing boobs jill has great
shoulders
hold on persia we know the best part of
persia's body
oh that leg inner thigh situation
nobody has anything like persia
right yeah you know what i used to say
any guy wants to date any of us they
should have just talked to the other
three
because secrets
sexy things maybe because we've been
talking about this before
i had a dream that we did the walk like
the challenge
oh my gosh and we were so good but then
when i thought about it when i woke up i
was like
oh my god they're up and down and i was
like
well who can do the splits here i can
still do this
okay do you remember the night first of
all
everybody knows that i never leave my
house but i usually there you go yes
do you remember when we couldn't get
into that club
and and we
[Music]
[Laughter]
wait persia you were there i was there
yes it was all four of us
were just not on the list or what was
the problem
we were not on the list
did we get in eventually eventually
but there was a lot of drama hit to the
east it was humbling it was humbling
it was it was you guys but you know what
that's what we have to talk about
actually
yes i'm so glad that our show is finally
getting the shine
yeah and that we are getting to feel all
these
20 years later yes we're getting to feel
what we made and the impact that it had
because while we were doing it
we couldn't get into clubs no no no no
at all it's true but we
there was no egos and that kind of way
like
that could happen sometimes
you know sorry go on jill i didn't mean
to wrap they were just curious why i had
this here it's just for aesthetic
i was trying to bring people into my
home with a little
little piano yeah
we were all finding our way and although
yes i know some of us had worked before
and we were all in
slightly different positions of sorts
but we were
all in the same place and yeah it all
happened at the same time and
um but we didn't get to feel our shine
we did it i mean during that time there
was no
instagram and we were inside of it yeah
there were
no girls there there was no social media
so everything we did
i think there was we had more at stakes
for us as artists
you know we couldn't hear what people
were saying unless we heard it on the
street
you know our in a in a magazine but you
know we still didn't even get that no we
hardly
so we had a lot riding on us as artists
and
as people and i think because we were so
fresh and new
i think we we really i know i was
incredibly sensitive
i was very protective and sensitive to
maya
and you know i think i fought for her
and i think all of us fought for our
characters the humanity of
our character that's one of the things
i'm proud of golden
is because i know certain
conversations and stuff and we all
fought for our characters yes
and and i do think honestly we had a
respectable way in a respectful way
yes absolutely but i also think we had
each other's backs
all four of us were so protective yes
of what we were trying to say and i have
to say that we as a cast
constantly spoke up and and
said like this doesn't feel right i know
this is what you guys think the
character is
or what you guys think is okay to say um
and i know persia
you you spoke up a lot too a little too
much
no i don't think that was good we all
had an opinion we all come from four
different walks of life and we had to
honor
you know each of our journeys and what
that what that dynamic felt like for us
we were protective of the girls that are
watching i felt responsible
if you saw something on the show that
you didn't like we probably had a
conversation
about it but then we can't win every
battle and we're here to do our jobs but
we try to arrest when it came to
not um objectifying the perception of
black women and and our own struggles
you know and all
our shades physically and emotionally
were different
and i felt like that was the gift that
we kept trying to get women in general
too
because yeah we felt like we are black
women but we're telling a
like a story of women right
women in general even though we had we
are black women but i really felt like
we did that
yeah we did express i hope that that's
what
crossed over i mean especially with that
episode you know we dealt with class
you know there's a class issue which
completely
um sometimes especially in this culture
might even trump race you know
i think if you're of a certain class
that episode where you know
tracy and i joan and i where i call you
classes and egregious but
that brought up so many dynamics just in
terms of who we are as a people
in this culture and um if you come from
money what does that mean if you don't
come from money if you're educated if
you're not educated
how does that connect you to another
person
and i felt like those were some topics
and i have to give
mara credit for that i mean she really
um
challenged you know our audience at a
very early age when no one else was
doing that
so i think that was um it was very brave
especially for black women to to sort of
tackle these issues
we were doing things that were
stretching
us and asking us to be public about our
point of views
you know and we all believed in the
power of representation and what we were
standing up for
in terms of the characters we were
playing and
it was a lot and i have to say like i
get chills i just yeah i'm
so proud of what we did but also so
proud of who we were
in that because i always say we weren't
the first to do it but boy did we do
that thing
right yeah the first but boy did we do
that thing
someone said what do you think the magic
was what was the magic why is it 20
years later still people
wanting this and it's coming out 20
years later and
i said to them and it was something that
we haven't told
everybody as a group at least one of the
most magical things for me was
when we did hit a bump in the road
sometimes the four of us
this is giving me goosebumps because i
would always pray
on my own and meditate and think i just
want to i
i want to be a voice and a positive
uh flow in this universe and when we
would all hold hands
and we would say just the four of us and
we do our own little prayer
was the most magical because we love
each other
we love the women of this world we want
them to be heard we want them to be seen
we
love our girls yeah all the way to
different countries
and whoever related connected to us we
cared about them and i just felt like
that was magical
we shot in front of an audience yes
so we did a show we went to a show we
would do pre-taped stuff on mondays but
we would shoot in front of an audience
and
it was like we were doing a show we were
doing theater remember how we just would
create a little
whatever it was and we just keep it
going we just keep the joke down
we didn't know how to let it die it's
spontaneous musicals
yes how about the fact that reggie moved
out
how about the time they banned us from
drinking kombucha
oh yeah okay no they banned jill and
golden they banned me too
oh jill you were red bull i was rainbow
girl no they banned me on red gold
it's because if you had too many red
bulls
you literally she you could not get
worse
[Music]
the speed line i thought it was the best
feed line reading
speaker was golden yeah yeah
i remember by the ends like i just when
you would read a script at home
you just i could hear your voices just
deliberately
pull up our hundred thousand how did you
get that
i kept it i haven't i have one i want
you guys to sign it
go mess up this zoom right now
get my drink yeah we're still in the
african-american museum are we still
there or was that just
you know i was just there jill um in dc
remember when i was there yeah and i
wanted to go it was closed because of
kovit but apparently we are
oh but i knew that we were there i
didn't know if it was just an exhibit or
if it was like
we were there to stay i think we're
there to stay
oh that's beautiful i mean that's so
special
another cocktail for everyone no that
might get ugly
that might get ugly golden okay i'll
leave her be so i'll close that you can
see me again right
yeah and the girlfriends are back what
do we feel about this
20th anniversary let's talk about just
what
what that means for us persia what does
the 20th anniversary mean to you
it means that we have
been around for a long ass time
yes and i cannot believe nature and god
has been so kind to us we're still here
and i feel better about life than ever
all of us have been
preaching this but for women to know
that
life just gets sweeter if you
develop your friendships and your soul
i mean i love you more all of you and i
feel more grounded and better about
myself even though age is scary
i feel better i don't want to go back in
time i want us to relive girlfriends for
fun like watch it on
on tv and then i want us to to be who we
are right now
and life is so precious so i'm just
happy we're all here
especially now guys beautiful person
don't you think
you know like especially i do i do i
mean i feel like uh
you know starting girlfriends we had
such um
you were just so bright-eyed and
bushy-tailed you know which was
beautiful and innocence is beautiful and
over the years
you you see the world you know through a
different lens
and um you grow like i said we've grown
with each other
um we've seen each other's bests we've
seen each other's
you know moments i'll say which is
beautiful because
that's that's why that's why that's
growth you know i mean i've cried with
each and every one of you i agree
with persia i don't want to go back i
love where we're going
i love being in this this new phase of
womanhood and
connecting and supporting each other and
and uplifting each other you know not
uplifting each other
oh girl you look good overall this no
but lifting each other up through spirit
through soul i'm so proud to know each
and every one of you
i'm just i just you know like i could
cry right now because
um i know if i ever needed just anything
if i just needed that ear
i could call each and every one of you
and i know for a fact that you'd give me
some type of
gem and jewel that would just
get me through my moment so i love each
and every one of you and thank you
i love you too that's what 20 years
means to me sorry
20 years mean to you jill a success for
me does not mean
monetary things and to me this is a huge
success in my life because i'm
like again i say i'm so grateful and i'm
so thankful i really do
look at you ladies as like family
members
i just feel like we did something so
beautiful
for not just women um
um and not just well for us
and we need this right now let's be very
clear about it we need this as black
women
right now we need it but for women as
well but also too for the culture man
like i
i didn't know that
it was gonna do what it did and
i'm just so grateful you know what i
mean like thankful
and grateful is like the best way that i
can
really describe um
this experience and i'm thankful for you
guys
because in reggie as well that's not
here because
i always say that i was in the
university of girlfriends i always say
i feel so proud of what we did together
and i think that the show
is like a tip of the iceberg of what the
four of us
walked through together um
and i think the energy of who we were
together
came through the screen but only we know
the intimacy and the truth of what we
all walk through together
and we will have that for the rest of
our lives absolutely
everything that each of you said in
terms of what we meant
for the world um what we meant and mean
for black women um what we mean for
ourselves
we love mara and are so grateful for
what she the platform she gave us
i too grew up in the university of
girlfriends
i became um and i think we all became
like we all
entered that show as really talented
lovely people
and we walked out of there as seasoned
vets
um we became women i feel like i became
a woman while i was on the show and then
i got to go become that woman
out in the world after i think of who i
am and all the things that i do
how i learn i found my voice on
girlfriends
i found it in the safety of what we were
doing
and also the fear of what we were doing
i mean
i look back and i think of the things
that we did and the way we showed up for
each other
in certain ways and the really hard
moments you know what i mean like we we
went through really hard moments
i mean i lost my step-dad while we were
at work we all went through some really
big things and i i learned some of my
biggest i feel some of my biggest life
lessons
in what we were doing together and i
jill when you talk about um what success
means i know that the world particularly
the world that we're in now
you know with social media and all this
there's a way that we define
success that's so external but to me
that there's this sense of the rock star
[ __ ] of life
what it really looks like you know what
it really feels like
you say like i'm here for tough
conversations but
the reality of what that looks like none
of us are ever really prepared for
and considering that first moment
jill that you spoke about when we were
supposed to dance and look like we were
friends and
having just met each other to 20
years later
you know 20 years later and yes i do
think god has been
very good to all of us we all mother
nature has been good to all of us
our teens have been good to all of us
but on top of that
like you think of the women that we all
are
and at the same time i think of who you
were
and you've just blossomed and become
more of that
all those moments that we all
were speaking up about like in a bubble
there was no social media mirroring us
back to us
we were each other's mirror we
held that anchor we were the girlfriends
we are the girlfriends we could also end
with
um and we don't have to end with a
prayer but i just keep thinking of that
moment before we would go out on
tuesdays
um and so if we were together we could
hold hands
and maybe we you know can just think of
one of those moments and give us a
prayer that we may continue
in our lives yes you um to show up
for the larger good for the greater good
um and for the joy that each of us
um holds in our hearts and and the way
we use our voices and the way we show up
personally in our lives and
professionally because we are all
continuing and yeah
i just want to say that um to the fans
who are watching
um we absolutely love you and you've
showed up for us
in a way that we didn't expect any none
of us
that like that was so beautiful and
you're continuing to support us
and you're here now then you know going
to be launching on netflix so
you can binge but this is a rough time
for our whole planet
and we love you just as much as we did
when we did that show
and we're still here for you showing up
we hope that's it
i'll continue on i love you all and
and all the fans i love you and i'm
sending you blessings from us too
so yeah beautifully said persh yes
love peace bye girlfriend
everyone
oh hell yes yes love you guys
love you bye